bring in our defense and security
analyst
michael clark now um
michael let's start where the fighting
is building up on the ground the donbass
region we talk about that regularly but
in particular mick alive as well and
talk to us about what's going on today
yes um the the russians are building up
some uh momentum at michele they've gone
towards the coast as it looks as if they
intend to initiate a second battle
battle of mikalayov sometime in the next
few weeks maybe approaching from the
south ukrainians are building up their
forces too it hasn't really started yet
but when it is
we will notice i mean meanwhile uh the
donbass of course is the center and the
russians uh last week had two or three
areas of advance those have more or less
stopped to be honest and they're putting
all of their effort into severe donetsk
and that is the that's the city that is
the the key to luhansk which is the
smaller of the two oblasts within the
whole dombash region and it's very
dangerous you're surrounded on three
sides and the key to understanding svery
done yet so we look at it a bit more
closely it's the river the sovereski don
yes river which runs right down to the
west of the of the city
and by and large that's a difficult
river to get across now the russians
have actually crossed it in some areas
and they've been pushing some of the
ukrainian forces south to kombucha
and some ukrainian forces have retreated
to comey shiva but others are going for
further north the ukrainians are pushing
some heavy armor up
from there as well in order to try to
hold the line but the key the real key
is the bridges over the the river there
are four bridges one of them has been
down for years of the other three the
northern and southern bridges um are
really covered by the russians the
ukrainians can't really use it the the
bridge that they can use is at a pavlo
grad and the bridge at pavlo grad a few
days ago was actually destroyed by the
russians it's one of the very few
sensible things they really have done in
this case and by destroying that bridge
of pavlo grad they've actually made life
very hard for ukrainians hard now to
supply severe donates from the west and
the ukrainians may have to decide do
they as it were dig in and survive and
just try to hold on and risk it becoming
another mario pole or do they give up
the city now and leave while they can
because with all the bridges down or
unusable they'll have to leave quite a
lot of their equipment behind and just
move out themselves that's a tough call
for any commander to make
and then one other point of interest i
think in this whole severo donetsk
battle is the fate of the terminator 2
this new the uh armored fighting vehicle
which the russians got very excited
about a few weeks ago in military
military terms it's a camel i always say
it's a tank chassis with loads of guns
loaded on top they've only got about 10
of them the british ministry of defense
confirmed they've got one uh one troop
really and they've gone to svere donetsk
and so all the uh the military train
spotters out there really interested to
see first of all is it vulnerable and
secondly will it make a difference as
and when the battle of slurio don yet
really get into the streets which it may
now do quite soon okay michael good to
talk to you thank you with that latest
update on what's happening on the ground
in ukraine